and
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
the pre-game
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos guys
as you know if you have watched two or
more of my lives and you do not
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
all right so to start the show why don't
we go around everyone say your name your
age your relationship status
and
um where you're from
who you're gonna start for me yeah go
and then go around yeah they call me
pound sterling
my age is 38 relationships there so i'm
happy and left
um i'm adeline
i'm 20 years old and i'm single
i'm emily i'm 31 and single
okay so um guys
the topic today
is are modern women delusional
so um i want to go around and why don't
we start with what is something that
frustrates you guys about dating
emily you can go first how much time
have we got for this one
um
what frustrates me about dating
ghosting
can be one of them
okay
it's close to the heart
ghosting
[Laughter]
sounds personal it's definitely personal
yeah does that happen often or no i
think once is enough oh okay you get
ghostly once that's gonna be sticking
with you for life it was like i feel
like that doesn't happen to girls as
much
um i beg to differ about that one oh
okay
does it happen i don't know does it
happen it does yeah you should be
ashamed of yourself
no not you lot the man you like should
do better i'm saying now we should we
should do better like if you're gonna um
stop speaking i have to courage your
convictions to just say just say listen
i'm not gonna listen something's not
working out or i'm not feeling something
about what's happening and we're not
gonna speak anymore i'm gonna go another
direction but the ghosting thing i don't
support it
okay so what about you guys um
just not stating what you want from the
start like
people who lack honesty
i don't see why you're scared to say
what you want maybe i'll side with you
maybe i won't that's for you to find out
do you feel like are you up front with
what you want
pretty much yeah okay yeah and you feel
like they are they like playing you like
they tell you one thing kind of yeah
kind of in the like way to coerce me or
something they wanna they wanna coerce
you what does that mean
like just to
lead me on and then okay at first
they'll make it seem like
they agree with me or they wanna do i
don't know just okay say for example i
want to get into a relationship they're
like yeah cool
and as soon as they get what they
actually want they'll cut oh like as
soon as they sleep with you they'll be
like yeah something like that okay but
yeah that's another real thing i can
speak from a man's perspective because
all of these things you guys are saying
um i hear about
and i i'm i'm very anti all of that kind
of stuff but it's a real thing now what
you're talking about it's very common
but there's a
degeneration now and men now will tell
you anything you want to tell a woman
anything you want to hear if you say i
like walks in the park they like walks
in the park if you like say like lily's
they're going to say we like lily's
let's go lily picking
do you feel like it's a thing because
girls like bat out of their league so to
speak
are you asking me yeah that's from like
a guy's point
i've heard that theory before you know i
don't i don't i think it's that because
i don't believe in out of your league
what when you say out of your league
what do you mean by really you don't you
don't believe in people have leagues but
no but i want you to define what you
mean because there's different there's
different ways i could take it okay so
like you rate someone one to ten so
we've got enough looks yeah it looks
see because it starts with blocks
but that wouldn't explain why they would
lie to you to get what you want because
hypothetically speaking if i'm a 10 and
you're a two i'm going to get what i
want easier i don't even have to really
lie i could just be like give me what i
want you should be happy to be around me
so you wouldn't really need to lie for
that so i don't think it comes from that
if that's a if that's the thought
process i think it just comes from a
thing of people are selfish now so
there's less of an urge for men to
protect women like they would have been
before like men used to like if you go
back generations and generations your
grandparents there was more of a thing
chivalrous look after women take care of
them protect them and so on and so forth
as time has passed now men are just like
i want what i want and that's it i don't
that's not my experience like i think
most guys
like there's a lot of guys willing to do
that it's just that girls don't want
them
girl you know women women rate the
majority of men is unattractive i think
it's like 80 90 of men women rate
unattractive
i think women i often say women overlook
some good men you are ignoring the bin
man the pulse man some regular guys you
don't want the flag guys but the flag
guy's got a lot of options so you're
just another one like the bin man and
postman
more appreciative hard working getting
on with their day-to-day trainer you
know and you don't want him no but
that's what i mean when i say like girls
are batting out of their league because
they're going for the guy that every
girl wants
and so
like of course like that's gonna happen
when you go for the guy that everyone
wants
because he'll sleep with a bunch of
girls but like who's he going to commit
to yes so maybe it's not that there's no
maybe it's not out of their league it's
just the wrong choice because she could
be a 10 he could be attempting but his
mentality is wrong because he his
mentality is that i've got all of you so
why do i need you so it's not
necessarily at the league it's just
a mentality thing like i guess
i wouldn't know because i've always been
a good guy
yeah yeah you've never ghosted a girl no
no no i'm not girlfriend i was never
ghosted i never goes through that right
you know ghost is a struggle word now
though you think i'm good and i just
jump out like boo i'm here so it's i'd
be honest and upfront and just be like
listen it's not working out i'm pretty
much a straight talker okay
um what about you guys do you think that
do you think women have
do you think women's standards nowadays
are realistic
to an extent it depends on who it is
but some girls agree with them
i think we know what we're getting
ourselves into a long time
that's what i say i feel like
i feel like most of the time when like
that happens like girls kind of have a
sixth sense or like this guy's up to
something
but we do it anyway and then
like
when we cry on the internet
[Laughter]
we know our friends know
everyone we know what we're getting at
we know they're t's and c's where it's
going to go wrong
but we can't help ourselves why do you
think that is i'll just go for vibes
yeah
but the guys with the vibes those are
the smooth talkers like they had to do
something to get that way
which is like a lot of hoes yeah it
works
it's that short fix of attention isn't
it
yeah i think for a lot of us
it's that short fix and we know it's not
going to last very long but we still we
still get it it's great weather it's a
great one
it's like crack you know what's
interesting um
80 if you ask 80 of women what they want
in a man they list 20 of men
so the reason that women hate men is
because we're all sleeping with the same
ones
because like do you guys have a height
requirement that you would
i actually i actually don't yeah
no height
how tall like um
minimum six foot three oh six do you
know what percent of guys are saying you
just can't talk about a big percentage
of the board
no i don't know so i i don't actually
know what it is over six three but over
um
six foot is
fifteen percent of men
so i'm assuming i would guess six three
is like ten percent probably less and
then so then let's say let's say like
you're not going to date the six three
guys that are ugly right
it depends actually
you'll be an ugly guy
medium rare medium medium so medium ugly
six three medium ugly and higher so
again like let's say you knock out then
at least 50
of those guys because they're not your
type or whatever um then that's only
five percent now let's say you add on
income like he has to make a certain
amount of money okay he ever
has to make the same as me more than me
how much um you don't have to say
exactly but how much do you want him to
make
like if you got what you wanted
don't disclose that information
that's not like one gold digger so he's
just like
do you want a guy to like takes care of
you though um
i wouldn't necessarily say take care of
me but if he would like to i don't mind
but i can actually take care of myself
okay so income isn't as big but height
oh that's that's serious
how tall are you i'm five foot eight
five eight okay
that's all right
i like to wear heels a lot so that's
fair he has to be taller than me in my
heels at least because
too many guys are short
so sad
so
um question
since women like have
are able to say like i want a guy that's
taller than me do you think men should
be able to say like i don't want to date
fat girls
that's right chess they should be able
to say that with chess yeah if that's
how they feel
why not i mean
you like what you like in it um you just
said you don't like no if he's under six
foot like what because like what if the
guy was like whatever i'm just saying
you like what you like yeah i'm going to
agree with you
because it was funny because we can like
as girls we could talk about this openly
but if a guy says like oh there's too
many fat girls around no but you know
what it's like
the way guys go about it because
sometimes the fat girls aren't even
checking for them
what sorry some sometimes the fat girls
aren't even checking for them but they
just feel the need to slander them
anyways
like me i'm not going around saying i
don't like guys under 6 foot 3 like
you're ugly i wouldn't go up to some
short guy in the street and tell me
no but girls but girls say things like
men are trash men ain't [ __ ] many like
like girls talk [ __ ] on men all the time
but the second a guy does it back like
all hell is broken it's like
i wouldn't
i'd be like it's just off of like a
small experience that they had i don't
think they send it for all men but the
men that it applies to you
are the ones that are getting
triggered with girls yeah the girls that
the girls that it applies to gets
triggered yeah i don't get triggered
it's not me absolutely i think maybe
because yeah i think everyone's entitled
to say what their personal preferences
are yeah so if a man decides that he
doesn't want you know a more
fat is a strong word
fluffy
you know i think it's down to the
individual that's how i'd be looking at
if i've got a personal preference that i
don't want that's for me to decide and
if a woman feels the same way okay
that's fine yeah that's for them to
decide that's how i see it but you're
not gonna tell me you're not gonna try
and attack me because i say i don't want
her to to be with someone that's you
know
a certain whatever okay but we do get
attacked often and i'm glad that you
brought that to the forefront yeah we do
men do well even if i hear guys say like
i won't date a single mom like girls
freak out yeah like why not for that i
i'm not going to comment on that no
please do
something like i don't really
dive into that type of topic so it's
just like
i don't know
i'm here for it what are you saying well
i just think like whenever men say they
want to have standards they're shamed
for it so if they say like i don't want
a girl that's fat i don't want to go
with kids i don't want to grow this like
like men will be immediately shamed
but but women can say i want a guy that
makes six figures he needs to be six
foot tall he needs to have this this and
this
he but
and no one will say anything i agree i
i agree i think women often have a lot
of like
their lists their tick boxes but
actually they're not bringing much to
the table themselves yeah see i don't
know see for me i think that it's i hear
what you're saying and women do do all
of these things and
and a lot of the times i say i feel like
it's everything's in the men's favor
right now if you're
if you're on point
yeah that's a small percentage of men
shout out to us
but
i understand what you're saying but for
the rest yeah it's going to be a tough
time but if you're on point it's
definitely everything's in your favor
right now as far as the criteria that
women are putting out for themselves
because they're you're you're you're
making the pool smaller and smaller
you understand what i'm saying so with
the i don't want this he's got to have
that he's got to have this he's got to
do that yeah the pool's getting smaller
and smaller so the ones that
now have all of the
all of the things you've asked for
they've got they've got a broad spectrum
to choose choose from there that's why
you might end up getting hurt
well it's not conducive for families
and that's the problem is like 50 of
women over 30 are projected to be single
and childless
and like by 35 you you hit geriatric
pregnancy 90 of your eggs are gone by
30. um geriatric essentially
shout out rip kevin samuels for the
thing he was saying over there about the
over 35's and what do you say again
leftover women yep
i didn't catch it fully but i got the
general gist
leftover thing
do you think that's is that offensive to
you guys
i think that's kind of offensive that's
kind of harsh because that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's that's that's perfect
unless it applies for men to you i feel
it's quite realistic if one is in that
position myself being okay i'm not past
35 i'm 31
but
perhaps i could see why men might feel
that way about me it's not right i don't
agree with it
but i can understand it
i think it's it's somewhat true and it's
not it's not like a fun reality like one
day i'm going to be 35.
like hopefully hopefully i'll be married
but i don't know that yeah but
like i think it's honest at least like
guys are attracted to fertility and
youth
yeah but you can get the oh but
it depends what you want yeah because
you can you still get a relationship
i don't think you can get a relationship
at 45. so it depends what your outlook's
looking for you're talking about
children and and all of the above
obviously your time shortening but as
far as meeting someone and having a
happy relationship i don't think there's
an age limit on that because you could
meet someone at
whatever age yeah it was true but like
according to dating apps you're um
like 50 of your options are gone by the
time you're 30. so if you take the same
girl at 23 or at 20 and 30 if you take
like the number of matches she gets on
dating apps it goes down by 50 see this
is the thing
you're americans you love your
statistics for everything we're dealing
with we have to take life into
consideration and some kismet stuff
going on as well because sometimes
things just happen we're not it can't
all even those stats are obviously
there's obviously credence to those
stacks at the same time
there's still you know that variable of
life you could walk out right now bump
into someone and everything changes so
i'm not going to write off the ladies
demo over 35 just yet because you know
shout out my over 35 full easel with
that you know i still could be a nice
man don't let you know kevin break it
down it's still go it will still happen
at any time yeah but but is it likely to
the likelihood might it's mine it's
significantly down but it's not it's not
it's far from impossible that's true
it's far from impossible and like bear
in mind when you're like over 35 all the
20 year old where's the running are
chasing after you as what that is true
yeah that is actually true
no fiction so you so you have the
potential to turn the tables as well
and you know some of them will just be
looking for fun but some of them you
could potentially if that was the
direction you chose to go you could
potentially mold them a certain kind of
way as well just like men do when when
we have our second um our second go
around and decide all right it's not
worked out you i'm gonna get my girl
she's 23 and we're going to have a
relationship now you understand so i'm
just saying that i don't i don't want
the over 45 to be feeling all down and
depressed right now so i'm trying to
help you that out
it's not about making them feel down and
depressed it's about being it's not it's
about being
but i'm being honest yeah i'm a listen
i'm the oldest person in the room yeah
so i've i've i've experienced life i've
seen things i know people of all age
ranges and i'm just saying that it's not
a riot for you i know a lot of women of
this age are not a lot of women that
might be single and a lot of women that
find happiness at these ages so even
though statistically the odds are
against you it's not impossible that's
all i'm saying that's true that's true i
mean if you if you're in shape you're
above like i don't know what it is here
but you're if you're in shape you're
above like what 75 of women that's just
there you go for a start yeah when you
see some of them you get like a banging
body at their like
so it's it's not it's not the end-all
be-all but
that's not that's but that's the
exception not the rule most people don't
most people don't age like better what
would you
establish here from what you've said so
yeah
if you're a fat single mom over 35
you better get to the gym right now get
yourself
get your [ __ ]
get your [ __ ] back get yourself in the
gym and help out because if you have got
a banging body and listen there's some
women
in their 30s and 40s you see them in the
gym they're going hard on that step
machine they're in an incredible shape
they're they're getting in shape like
they're they're their future husband
just like yeah
they're like yeah they're getting hard
and they're gonna go even harder after
this they're going hard no don't blame
them yeah letting them carry on carry on
sorry i'll just say i'm just saying but
like i think it makes sense like single
like people over 35 are the leftover the
women because they're ones no one else
picked
like that's not necessarily pearl no
you're you're being harder than them and
i'm not a simple
i'm not a sim let me just be clear sorry
it's just the time that you used like
left over
yeah that's what i'm saying still get
consumed
past the expiry date oh at the same time
that's the buyer
no oh gosh oh gosh what do you think
about that let me know i've been
speaking enough what do you think nah
just
yeah i don't want to say nothing about
this one all right over 35 i don't want
to think about it i'm too young for this
you're too young i worry about that
and there's my approach in my late 20s
it can happen
i'll say that this it could also be
sometimes it could be a good woman
that's been left because of a bad guy oh
yeah she's treating your whole life in a
relationship or something
yeah it could be that too a good woman
that's been
hurt or left by a by a bad guy
it might not even be her fault so she's
not really left over well she picked him
i literally think it's your own fault
where you end up i like how you think i
like it like anytime
people can switch up at any time but as
a woman we have intuition and we just
talked about earlier how we always
know that feeling
30 years into your marriage what imagine
you've got you spent 30 years in your
marriage now
and you got
the feeling but that's an exception
that's not that's not the rule like come
on you don't you don't know guys that
are stable committed good husbands and
after 30 years they just drop and leave
it happens it happens but it's not it's
not common
because women file 70 to 80 of divorces
if they're college educated they follow
90 of divorces
so women are the ones leaving it's not
man true we're leaving because of them
normally i think i take what you say on
board to be fair because i blame
myself in a way for my last long
relationship in four years he cheated
numerous times oh jesus and essentially
sorry it was my fault for saying yeah
i've been cheating now
right well i'm not gonna blame myself
for him cheating because that was his
that was his choice
oh okay
yeah i picked him true you picked her
staying staying is another it's another
side of it right yeah she used to stay
with him that's on me yeah yeah and i
did and now i'm 31 and i've been single
for four years yeah i take a part of
that
on on me because i shouldn't have stayed
for that long and wasted my time with
someone
who was consistently showing me that i
shouldn't have been with them so i do
take them on board
yeah
no i agree i just think like every in
relationships we we pick who like and we
attract what we are so if you keep
attracting shitty people it says
something about you
like no i'm serious good you're not
lying big facts like good good like
and
no one's perfect so
yeah but if if it's like toxic
relationship after toxic relationship
after toxic relationship there's a part
of you that's toxic there definitely is
there's many bad women that choose
bad relationships over and over again
listen see when i talk when i was just
talking and i'm talking for the good
women i can very much different
differentiate the good women may i say
and the [ __ ] and the hoes i'm very
good at differentiating between those
particular sectors you get me so
if you if you're moving a certain way
and then you've ended up on a pile
because you've been out partying every
night for the last 15 years that's your
fault i ain't going to sympathy for you
you should have kept your ass indoors
try to be a better woman and a man might
put a ring on it but instead you was out
in the club
doing all kind of madness twerking
busting it whatever you're doing and now
look at you you just
feel like indoors every day i don't
think i didn't say every day but come on
there's not every day there's a big
difference between every day and just
being out every weekend and stuff i feel
like there should be an equal balance
of course not but there must always be
balance but if you're out every weekend
what is there out every weekend for you
and you've got a man the men are always
out every weekend where they are every
weekend the menu no no no no no no no no
no it's the men you pick that are out
everywhere all right
there are a lot of good guys yeah
there you go that's what it is
because when i look out every weekend my
guy's not i can see by the way my
engineer there's nothing he's not out
every weekend sometimes you're just cool
he's here
yeah that's what that's my plan
that's a good hard working man
contention so it's not every man every
weekend but if you don't want to be out
every weekend don't complain because a
lot of the times you're not going to
meet the good guy in the club people go
to clubs and bars for a reason at times
you know so and that manda is so quick
to talk to you like come on come on come
on that's the same thing he's done he's
practiced his art yeah you're not the
first girl you're not the first and you
won't be the last
you understand so it is what it is so i
agree with you on that part but for the
good girls them there's hope but for you
like they're just expecting it to happen
in the same spot out every week
stumbling out drunk every week from the
club no we see you coming we see you
coming from a mile off we line you up
oh when i'm just telling you i'm just
telling you
the game the game is the game wow
the game is the game well that's what
i'm saying like a lot of girls confuse
sexual attention with relationships yeah
they'll think of guys that like he's
giving them sexual attention so that
means she's on that level but she's not
like like i've had
guys in in the nba hit on me i know
they're not trying to wife me no it's
not impressive they do this to everyone
like
like
are you gonna wife anyone are they you
don't see them move on and even when
they're doing it
no they there's nba wives they just
cheat on them exactly but they no one's
special in that environment are they no
i would say those girls are like special
and they did do something right they're
just willing to put up with it yeah and
i don't think guys and guys and girls
cheating is different like men and women
they don't cheat the same
tell them again it's different
no no because a man can still love a
girl and cheat on her but like i don't
think women can it's just
yeah i agree with that no
don't get me wrong like but it's a whole
different ballgame for women i feel as
far as she's a whole different kind of
energy and a whole different kind of
bull game
because she's trying to do better if she
cheats on you she thinks she can do
better and she's trying better in what
department like what whatever you're
lacking as a dude
as amanda's never been cheated on i'm
very interested in this and i would know
if i had i'm not saying it from a place
of you know arrogant i'm saying it from
a place of certainty i've not been
cheated on my shit's official patterned
correct but i'm very interested to hear
this conversation so you're saying when
women cheat they're doing it
what they're trying to think they're
going to level up okay okay so i
remember the day and i'm sure you had
this moment when you realized you have
to worry about the ugly girls too oh
absolutely yeah because because guys no
no because guys will cheat they'll do it
guys will cheat with a girl they would
never or they will sleep with a girl
they would never be seen in public it
would never be like bring her into
daylight
but but
women when we like when we cheat we look
first we're looking for something our
partner doesn't have yeah so if girls
cheat they cheat up maybe the guy is
better looking maybe he has more money
maybe he's better and better i don't
know what it is something that will
benefit them
yeah but girls aren't just gonna sleep
with a homeless guy that goes up to them
no
and has nothing going for him
unless he's really
hot we're not going to sleep without
again the man in my wildest demands
i've always been broke
we'll put it wherever you're at for the
most part
it's the animal that's what you just
said animals right i said they put it in
animals
oh so
but no i think it's just that yeah the
caveman in us that animal thing that
urges you know if you it's hard to get
uh control of you have to be
strong-headed to be able to deal with
certain things men are led around by our
dicks a lot of the time i generally
think it's in your dna it is i've
actually i don't have to realize that it
is in our dna and it's something if you
can get control of that mm-hmm then you
can you can navigate through life very
easily a little bit i want control over
it
they genuinely want to enjoy that
caveman instinct and they want to
control it or reign in it's a primal
urge listen
we were you know hunters and whatever so
i was going to say hunters and gabriel
the words from my mouth so you know that
we all have that primal urge we can't
help it we are who we are
you know there's a time when if we
bedded several women and slaughtered men
we'd be celebrated in arenas and that's
not that long ago we understand so
that's still in our dna well because
it's harder for guys like you have to
build yourself up in order to do that a
girl just has to exist
you have to breathe so so
on that topic do you guys think body
count matters
for men and for women it's a very
different subject isn't it vice versa
for me personally from women to a man
know but i understand it's very crucial
the other way around yeah very crucial
like we don't care about their body
count but they can't they don't want
someone that's been passed around yeah
they don't
more times they have their higher body
count but as well
that's why
a man should have the higher body count
let's be realistic but
it's not guaranteed now
i've been putting in work from nowadays
these women are putting in work from
early
there's young girls talking about some
body count levels that they're like
let's say you're 20 i'm not going to go
into it but there's some 20 year olds
there are some there are some yeah no
but the guys they're on the map the guys
who do you think they didn't no no
that's nice thank you who do you think
they do
but it's a it's a again it's a different
kind of team but it's a small percentage
of men so one in three men
under the age of 30 either have not
slept with anyone in a year or more
that's why or are conditions
so no no so again like we're going back
to it's a very small percentage of men
so when you're saying like oh the men
are wild like that's right you're not
you're not talking about men you're
talking about
the chats like the
the hot guys like you're talking about
five ten percent i've seen some ugly
guys
you see but you have to understand even
the two even even the guys that you
think are ugly they're getting no no
even the guys that you think are ugly
are probably satisfying like a couple
biological things that women look for so
like for example for example like
they're probably tall they might be ugly
or less attractive but they're probably
tall and the funny thing is the funny
thing is like usually when i see
girls call guys ugly a lot of times they
call guys ugly that i would say facially
have a more symmetrical face than them
yeah i don't i don't even like when
people call people ugly really as a
thing so so like i'll i'll rate people
because i do this like sort like because
i try to get people on my show right but
you can rate people like one to ten and
the way i do it is like eight like it's
a kevin samuels he had this scale eight
to ten is like model five six is like
pretty cute
and so like a lot of times i'll see
girls like call guys ugly but like i
literally think they're on the same
level
so like even the usually even the guys
that like they call ugly like still
satisfy something because otherwise you
know girls
no girl is going to sleep with a guy
that's broke ugly and that meant that
that meant that mandy called him sure
he could be the good guy the one that
could be the good guy always ugly man
making sexy money
see it there he could be the good guy
making bread he could be the protector
provider he could be the good guy yeah
but the the problem is
like women are we can't undo our biology
and like women aren't attracted to like
we're still attracted to the [ __ ]
trait which isn't necessarily an [ __ ]
to the ability to stand up for yourself
and a lot of guys like are too too nice
they don't have a backbone it's not
really nice it's like they just don't
have a backbone and they don't know how
to stand up for themselves they might be
like
a good quote-unquote good guy but you
don't want a guy that's like not going
to lead you and i can only put you in
your place ever 100
that's i always say it comes down to the
dna and the core essence of a man and a
woman you know so i always say with a
woman is unemployed that runs a fortune
500 company know at the essence of
things when it really gets down to it
she's going to want a man to lead
and i don't think that changes in
anything in any standpoint i'm never
going to change my mind on that so when
women are like oh yeah i'm a boss [ __ ]
i do this
i just think you haven't met the right
man to kind of put you in to put to put
you in your place basically and kind of
like
let that you trust enough to take the
will to be like okay i respect you i
admire you enough you take the will and
lead you know they might fight against
it and they'll be like i don't want that
i don't want this but i think when
they're doing all of that they're
testing so when women are harsher man i
don't complain when i see women are hard
on men and they're like
talk to them a certain way or this that
the other i don't complain about that
because i think that's what they should
do
to find out if you are you man enough to
leave my man in lead and look after me
so i don't have any problem if you're
rude if you dissed it out like i won't
accept it personally but i understand
why women do it because they have to
test to see because it comes down to
that same thing are you man enough to
come i don't i don't think so i don't
think there's nothing you agree with me
i don't think there's an excuse for
being an [ __ ] today i didn't say beer
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold
on
hold
on
where did you save yourself
i didn't think there was anything about
the women yeah the women no i don't
listen it's up to you this is my fingers
people can do whatever they want yeah
there's no excuse it's up to you how you
deal with it when they yeah that's my
point that she could say well you can do
what you want you could be the biggest
idiot you could be the dumbest [ __ ] on
earth
it's up to me if i'm gonna accept it if
you're such a [ __ ] that you're gonna
let her talk to you like that then
that's your prerogative
she
i'm just saying that as if she's
entitled to do it if she can do it and
get away with it it's the man's fault
it's not her fault it's the man's fault
because no one ain't gonna talk to me
like i'm a fool you just get put in
place one time or i won't deal with you
and that's that and we move
uh no i still think it's i think it's a
girl's fault if you're being a [ __ ] for
no reason no if a girl's being a [ __ ]
it's a girl being a [ __ ] to the guy i'm
talking about yeah like accept it that's
it that's his parochial don't give me
like yeah but there are some girls i
know what you're talking about there's
some girls some girls are just [ __ ]
for no reason that's actually a
personality trait
you can't fix that that's that means
she's like that day-to-day personality
yeah
people there's people like that for no
reason it's up to you to entertain role
is a big thing in that department i
think
of knowing what the right guy is and how
to spot them and what to look for
oh my gosh
i agree i
oh my gosh i call my dad actually and i
tell him about the guys i'm dating i
could not do that no no no no no no no
no it's not an american thing
you call your dad and talk about the
guys
no most americans don't do that oh
exactly no no
i'm way too close with my family thing
that's cool though no but it's actually
helped me to be honest because i'll be
like okay like this this this and this
and i'll tell him and then he'll like
like i listen to what he says i just i'm
like you can pick my husband because i
don't want to
i would want look at the letter
the last time i didn't listen i ended up
in like a very toxic relationship so i
was like i learned my lesson i was like
i'm going to talk to you
sort of they're somewhere adopted but
yeah okay
you're living the dream over there yeah
yeah no it's
it's good but that's why i like i
genuinely think like father should be
more involved in like hundreds like i
think a lot of like every i swear to god
every time i haven't listened to my dad
or my brother is like i've ended up in a
situation because we know they know they
know the mind state of a man they know
the master of a man as a man you know
the mind state of other men
more than women and there's certain
things that we want
only a dad or a brother will tell you
like when i have female friends i always
say i tell them a lot of things and i
say to them i want you to know
everything i know so you don't miss the
tricks and you don't miss things but
sometimes you don't want to listen you
have to learn the hard way which we do i
mean depends who the role model is
because that's right my dad's telling me
this i'm like why are you cook looking
but if my male friend is telling me this
maybe i have to open my ears
if your dad is your dad is is he like
why wouldn't you listen to him because
he's just like
on my case like i think he just doesn't
want me to get married at all because
i'm like his baby girl so he's like you
can't talk to anyone that's all you
can't marry you can't marry anyone don't
look in a guy's direction and get so
protective over me like i understand i
think it comes out of a place of like
you don't think if you had like a good
guy interested in you he would be okay
with it no really what about over the
test of time like if they were
consistent
he'd probably kill him
no you don't no he's too protective i
respect but that's why i always said i
didn't want daughters because i think
that's how i would be i've always said i
don't do as i don't do this because i
think that's i'd be so protective
because i know how men are mm-hmm i'd be
i'd
yeah it would be like knocking the door
and bad boys you know
bad boys and will smith and ramen's dick
it'll be like that they could it
couldn't you know it couldn't work
he'd be knocking down the door
of like every guy literally literally
everyone's getting bought into the um
the back room like 50 cent in den of
thieves i'm having all the man them
around there they they they're gonna
want to come right there again
so when when do you guys think it
becomes
because on one hand i do like i do think
women should
like have standards right i'm not i'm
not saying women should have no
standards but at what point is it
delusional
when they can't even attain what they
want in the man so say if they want a
really rich man
does the rich man want you though you
need to think about that yeah because
it's a two-way street
so you need to be able to meet his
expectations
so that he can meet yours as well
if you have them expectations don't get
mad when he doesn't want you
if you can't
keep up to what he wants
but yeah that's my perspective at least
i have the same same thing i always
thought about what you were saying as
well that women should bring something
to the table when it comes to that if
they're expecting a lot they should be
giving a lot
but i had a conversation with a male
friend a few weeks ago and he mentioned
to me that actually a lot of guys don't
care
about what girls bring to a table if
they're the providers they don't and
they they couldn't care if she works
doesn't work
doesn't drive they don't care i've
always been under the illusion they do
no but i've only learned recently in my
31 years and i feel like they're the
ones
but they care they do care about um
they care about your like body yeah they
care about the way you look they just
care about they don't they don't care
about what we care about because we care
about if a guy drives we care if a guy
has a job like a lot of times like girls
will think that guys evaluate them the
way we evaluate men so we'll be like oh
i'm funny he wants a girl that's funny
like all right
they don't know
they're like is she is she hot is she
available
does she like me back
yeah it's true men go off the physical
men do you go off the physical but for
me
i'd say not like yo what did you say
your girlfriend said you don't care if
you like it doesn't care what girl is
meant to be because i don't i'm
so i don't care
what they earn or anything like that but
what i do care about is
a work ethic
yeah that's what i care about work ethic
because if you're just coming and you
just want to be you just want to there
with your hand out that's not attractive
to me but if you've got a work ethic and
i know you're a grinder you want to get
things done you want to work then i want
to look after you i want to put you in a
position where you have to do less or
nothing at all but if you've got some no
work ethic you're just sitting there you
want to just sit look pretty next to me
what's that going to do for me i want to
see once if the work ethic is the thing
the that side of you where you want to
do for yourself that's attractive a bit
of ambition you know so you don't have
to be making loads of money you could be
in a doing whatever but you've got
aspirations you want to achieve things
or certain things that's attractive not
if you're laying in bed till
half two and then you won't get up for
the pin go party and then no we're not
doing all of that
do you think most guys care about that
depends what you want yeah not going to
lie to you if i just want to smash then
i'm not going to care
you could you could if if your heart and
my own instinct is that i want to
bend you over then
you could be flipping
sleep all day part of your nights
i'll catch you in between you understand
but so now most guys don't care to be
for the most part if you're hot i've had
conversations like this on my podcast if
you're demanding don't care well and the
other thing is girls i think girls think
that guys care about their money so
they'll say things like oh i'm like the
one thing girls will say is like i'm
independent yeah but when i
this is this is just a feeling as a girl
and you tell me as a guy if this is true
i think when a girl is like oh i'm
independent i don't need a man a guy
puts her in the friends with benefits
category because like guys want to be
needed and they want to be like wanted
um
when i hear it i don't really take it
seriously because i think like you think
they're capping yeah
because you know what it is like
the king don't need to say he's the king
the lion don't need to say he's a lion
so the fact that you're declaring this
to me is i just think it's just sound
you heard and it sounds cute like that
so i don't take it that's it i kind of
pinch or sort that and keep it moving no
i feel like you can be independent and
not
want like not need a man but you can
still want one mm-hmm yeah
yeah i'm independent i provide for
myself but i don't mind a bit more you
know i mean like no no all day long what
i'm referring to is the one that will
tell you and keep announcing it i'm
independent i don't you see what i'm
trying to say that i'd rather you prove
it yeah just show i'll see it you know
like we'll see i'll see that okay
she's independent she doesn't think that
that kind of thing rather than that
announcing i don't need a man i do this
i don't need to hear all of that [ __ ] i
thought it was attractive to men
too until recently well i thought men
wanted women that said i'm independent
and i soon realized they don't care
if they want to provide
i like strong women i like successful
women i do like stronger successful
women because then to me i
that's more attractive to me like when a
strong successful woman
bends to my will or tells me to take the
steering wheel that's more of a thing
than some woman that just needs me
anyway she's like i'll do that but when
you've got your own thing going on and
then you say you know what i respect you
you take the wheel on control that's
that's that's
when you're doing some lion but it's
interesting because a lot of
a lot of times if you sell a girl like
that to submit to a guy it's like hell
is freezing over of course i can't
submit to a guy
yeah have you heard that at all um
i have
but it's like
there's some it's probably the girls
that actually are independent that go
that
the fake ones they'll be like okay calm
all right let's do this well there has
to be a leader and a follower in a
relationship
even even some girls do leads
give it something
yeah but they but they they don't like
their the guy there
someone actually do
crazy they don't
because if they really like you they're
submitting i'm just being i don't want
to say too much but if they really like
you they're submitting and i've seen it
they'll start with that attitude that
you spoke of they'll start with the no i
don't want it they hate the idea of it
but you know
it's as we said earlier it's in the dna
it's in our course i feel like it's
possible
it's more than whispers like for a woman
to lead a woman to lead it's possible
not without resenting the guy
oh you shouldn't they shouldn't they
shouldn't be leaving i personally don't
know that
i've seen people and they look pretty
happy are your parents together yeah
your mom leads
no exactly this is my point in theory it
sounds good i know in reality then my
your mom might lead in a way where you
think it's like your dad's lack i'm just
kind of bothered he's letting the lead
but really and truly for the most part i
think men will lead no but even now when
my dad leads i just look at him
that's because i don't know that's cause
your generation you're the new
generation so now the times are changing
so you're looking at things different
but like we said before it's uh it's
been going on for a long time
it's a good thing times are changing
though because yeah he said the man and
we're leading a bit too like i don't
mind the mad leader
unless he has sense
if he's senseless then it's pointless
for him to leave obviously she
okay if a girl wants to leave she can do
that but she's not going to like the guy
thank you because
women create like we're attracted to the
trait leadership like if a woman okay
okay i'll give you an example if a guy
is a ceo
and he's powerful
that is hot to us that's sexy a
president that's sexy okay ceo of
men and that if a man is as a woman ceo
it's cool
but it's like it's like a shoe
collection to us
so if a dude is a shoe collection it's
cool but i don't we don't care
it's it's whatever and that's what it is
to them so
the
what we're attracted to isn't a guy
that's that's like
that doesn't have the leadership
qualities
and so it's um
yeah i mean they can do it and some
girls do but they always they always
hate their husbands
you put that so wrong
so poignant so true no i couldn't i
couldn't have said it better myself no
but then a lot of women who hate their
husbands are the ones
that are submissive as well
pretending to be maybe
not even what do you mean submissive to
their husbands
so the husband's like
the lead the leader of the relationship
and they hate them
because they're saying then it's the
wrong kind of leadership yeah that's
yeah that's true it depends
it's the wrong kind of leadership
it might not really be leadership it
could just be bullying or overpowering
them in a situation and then that's
wrong
a real real submission should that we're
talking of is a more kind of
do you guys think it's um
okay do you think it's fair for women to
want traditional men that pay and take
care of them and take us on dates all
that stuff well we're not traditional
women so like we're not virgins anymore
we're not like we don't offer the
traditional yeah
no i'm just saying no no i didn't hear
you go ahead if you want a traditional
man you have to be a traditional woman
like don't get mad when he expects you
to stay at bst at her mom quick and
clean and stuff like that
because that's how it works
but yeah you put it that's why i don't
want a traditional man because i know it
comes with that price
at the price of
really i would
if i could stay home i'd be chilling
stay at home all day oh yeah i mean look
after the kids clean when he comes home
and washes yeah watch his underwear like
that's just again i'm going to ask did
your mom do that stuff
yes
yes
i don't like that but just saying you're
fighting against you're fighting against
it but it's there for you to see and
it's been successful your parents are
still together because they're
successful just because they're together
doesn't mean it's successful that's true
that's not something i inspire you you
know so i'm asking though your parents
have so you're saying they're not they
can't be happy but i wasn't the
happiness the success i mean like for
you for them not for you for them yeah
but for me
that's not what i
personally i understand i'm just i'm
just saying for them they've achieved
happiness for them yeah
you don't think that's an indicator of
success
that's the point i'm trying to make yeah
but it's like 50 of marriages end in
divorce so the fact that your parents
are still together and don't hate each
other is a w
huge that's that's huge after how long
have they been together it's
over
over five years
and you don't think there's anything you
could learn from that relationship i
mean i can pick up a couple of things
right it's like don't get tricked don't
get tricked out of a position where
these the
the new the feminism lies to women
it lies no radical feminism does i think
all feminism i don't think we need
feminism in 2022. i think it's outdated
and there's nothing that i can't do
today that a man can do there's no
nothing legally in my way
like there's no law we're fighting for i
i don't see the name right that's
different for every woman so like say
for example me and you uh-huh you can
walk into an office and demand a job
they'll give it to you if i ask for it
they'll be like what is this black
monkey doing here like get out
and then say for example you and a man
if you both walked in okay say for
example you and the white man okay
okay he's more like oh sorry he's more
likely to get the job than you there's
still that type of
thing
that's not true that's not true the wage
gap doesn't exist
it doesn't when you take into account
the diff no it doesn't like any any
psychologist that's worth assault will
tell you that it does not exist the
people that the people that the people
that
are that that talk about that are
reiterating it for their political gain
they're saying that to confuse you and
to control you i mean i've seen it no no
no no so so the reason when you take
into account
personality differences
and and roles that women pick so women
tend to pick jobs that are with people
men tend to pick jobs with things so
therefore men make more money because
those jobs pay more for example men pick
engineering more than women that's a
very high paying career
men pick plumbing
bricklaying
garbage garbage collection that stuff is
that pays more than being like a
psychologist
i'm not depends because
um
studies that i've seen so i did a study
on like
basketball okay it's quite evident the
men get paid a lot more than me because
they bring in because because they bring
in more money i know they're bringing
more money but so so why would you pay
someone if they're not making money like
that's like me that's like if you have
more money they could probably perform
to the level where they'd get the same
amount of money no they don't they don't
no no they don't the wnba is at a 10
million loss every year they lose money
they don't make money
so so that's like me having 10 salesmen
and the men
bring me in let's say 50k each a year
then women lose me 20k but are they
given the same facilities because you
could be giving these men fancy offices
and then the women's workforce
do you think that lebron james dunking
is more entertaining
as equally as entertaining as like the
one or two women that conduct
a woman duncan is quite impressive
it's because men don't all the time
it's impressive it's impressive but is
it as entertaining
i think so well that's me either someone
else the exception or the rule do more
people want to watch the nba or the wnba
it depends on which one's publicized
more which is the mba but it's not as
publicized
no it's because men are men are better
at basketball well i didn't want to say
that's the bottom line i play i play
basketball
and even even at let's take uel
i'm sorry i'd rather watch the men's
over us true
wonder what makes us think that way
though
in what we in the sense that
as you mentioned before in terms of the
pay gap or the one doesn't exist
obviously men will take more laborious
jobs right so the more the engineering
things actually takes on the physicality
of a man yeah
hence why us women get paid less we do
the admin jobs the personal jobs yeah
when you're comparing it versus football
to football for example
my cousin she's a female she plays
football
she actually posts something yesterday
the pay gap in football is mad it's
crazy and iris and i see what you're
saying about what would you rather watch
but why is it why do you want to watch
men play football versus women's
yeah they have better facilities no
they're better because of the
physicality and the genetics the biology
who would win in an arm wrestling match
oh absolutely exactly that's different
things but you know in the sense of an
exactly it's the same game basketball
football it's the same game no but these
things do come into play strength yeah
yeah yeah
that comes into it does come into play
we're just better at it the closest i've
seen to the gap being pushed to a degree
is tennis with the williams sisters but
they're still yeah
where they play to such a level but
they're still decent yeah the 200th
ranked man beat serena williams thank
you i was about to say that
yeah like men are just better at sports
they're bigger they're stronger they're
faster so you deserve to get paid more
yeah they yeah because if you're better
at a job you get paid more available so
why don't they'll ever have a chance to
bridge the gap nice how so you're
battling against dna and genetics like
just the same way i think there's like
men will never bridge the gap in
modeling but you don't hear anything
about that
you don't hear men complaining oh we
don't make as much on only fans like
we don't even though even though it's
the same even though
that industry was built by men anyway so
most that's the men's fault anyway
what so only france like porn industry
that's basically built by men so it's
the men's fault that they don't get
enough views
i know so what's the difference
men watch sports
yeah yeah so i'm saying like like at the
end of the day you get paid for eyeballs
in both professions you get paid for who
watches more yeah and so one it's women
taking off their clothes and men taking
off clothes and in the other it's
playing a sport
yes so but i'm saying like why don't
nobody
rallies marches the streets
for i agree with you
for the men not getting paid enough to
model yes
i mean they're not really triggered by
it
no because men don't complain women do
women women women will complain about
everything i'm complaining if i earn
enough money
that the money you you'd complain if you
don't earn the money the if you're
earning the money you deserve to earn
basically i feel like they deserve it i
think they deserve less actually if
you're operating at a loss i think they
probably don't like if we're going to go
off with deserve like if if i had a
sales person and they were losing me
money like
ish right there he has a job because i
make more money on the streams than he
like than he costs
right
but if we if these streams were really
bad and every time i lost viewers every
time he came on like
he wouldn't be here and it's the same
thing with like the wnb and the nba
they have they have people yes if it was
performance related play related pay a
lot of these women wouldn't there might
be no basketball league for women um
but i think it's probably because it's
more recent thing
what's that you think as time goes by
women will get better
no because i feel like the men have had
a head start
if that makes sense so basketball
i didn't want to start patreon
a head start
no but in terms of like leagues these
are still new leagues uh-huh so
that's on tennessee because the demand
for the men's league was there like i'm
telling you people want to make money
people like
people will put anything on a screen to
make money if women's sports made money
it would be pushed
they just did the boxing the other day
in new york they did um
the big all-women's fight first time
every madison square garden
um katie taylor versus amanda serrano
that got a big push that was a landmark
moment
but again how much of that was partly
like
the novelty of it at the same time
because
you know men do that every week
um
and do you think women should box do you
like women boxing
if they like it then they like it i
personally don't like boxing as a whole
but they're saying if i don't mind they
might as well both box if two women were
boxing
and one and one of them battered bruce
get enough would you you think you'd be
more inclined to say stop the fight than
you would if it was two men
you're not in yeah
you've gone into fight and now you want
to stop the fight just continue
if she dies she does it's
nice i'm saying instinctively you might
want to like that emily said she would
be more inclined to say i would i would
yeah well and i would as well so i'm
saying it i think that's just me that
i'm like
she's like
she's like a lot of guys
why are you crying like hers making out
alive
okay do you want to read the super chats
i know we got yeah sure i forgot to do
this super chat let's get into this
what time is it
it's okay i've got 10 minutes i'll text
him and say that 10 minutes
right 10 minutes okay
all right we're ready yeah go ahead cool
nige miller uh two percent of men are
over six foot three
two
damn i don't mind being single collins
i really don't mind
ask the group to rate each other and
themselves out of 10. oh real quick
we're talking oh god okay i'm going to
rate myself
i'm
as well
definitely halfway in the middle what
are you giving yourself i would give
myself a five two
they can't say
i'll give myself a humble seven
five fair enough all right so first
all right let's go um mr demark six five
as a six foot two man in my fifties i
don't date women under 45 and the
selection is wonderful
see what happens with your tools
how many how is my man dissing americans
for using factual statistics that's our
reality pattern up bro
listen you just stay by your keyboard
man guys
belly here
people don't seem to realize that love
is a choice attraction is important in
the beginning but relationships are only
as strong as the people in them
pet shop
women on the couch opted to call fat
woman fluffy but also said it was sad
that most men were short why must we
sugarcoat things for women
it sounds like let me help him pick our
words for me high is a protected
characteristic no you fat being fat or
enough i said fat originally but he was
like oh let me pick a better term yeah i
never said it i don't care about it
okay
uh better question may have more
qualitative data rather than
quantitative data focus i'm sorry let me
say that again better question may have
more qualitative that rather than
quantitative focus example do women have
the right aim slash or are seeking for a
relationship are each about the
self-centered focus or is it about
loving one
uh peter patel with fifty dollars
[Music]
shout out to him uh expectations can
demand the impossible but low
expectations aren't better focus on
what's truly important to you in a
relationship rather than satisfying
passing fantasies do this you
so
doing this uh you will have to you have
no worry and being overly optimistic uh
peter patter once again with 50
uh we shouldn't really be looking for a
lifestyle accessory rather than a spouse
we've
we've unworkable expectations since
we're not seeing them as people more
like accessories
as if they are your own glory rather
than one you wish to care for
one two plus love equals one
um ballsy shout out to the big man on
the sofa talking facts
uh demark mr demarc65 as a father of
five daughters i want them to marry to a
good man uh then i work then i worry
then i won't worry about them as much
yes uh the body is not all a good man
cares about it is all the man is leading
you to his money if all the man is
leading to you is money and comfort
don't uh don't you know money doesn't
buy happiness
okay wayne williams do you know a rapper
called tom mcdonald
oh
no i don't know um
no ballsy do the
do the female panel submit to their male
partners quick one
yeah it depends i would go ahead yes or
no uh
yes
you would you would to the right person
to the right person yeah okay the right
person um
wait holly simp um
submission is ultimate vetting tool for
a man because a woman will not submit to
a man she does not respect
keep up the good work
uh zentians with fifty dollars
i know him
legend legend
to the black female guest your statement
about you walking
into a company asking for a job versus
pearl being denied is false affirmation
action so affirmative action
as guaranteed admission to jobs schools
purely based on color in the name of
equality rather than merit
oh that's nice okay um vic
quinn
uh just broke up with my non-traditional
girlfriend of eight months at university
right now during finals week
all because she wanted to be
able to have a lot of guy friends
fml oh what are you doing what do you
think they're not friends
they're not friends
oh yeah she was trying to she's trying
to she's living the whole she's doing a
whole summer's coming up
okay five five pounds from samantha the
top inner international australian
women's footballer team lost to a under
15s boys team 7-0
another one from zentians thank you so
much what is all of this with deserve no
wonder men in general think a large
percentage of women are delusional no
one deserves anything it's all earned
you do not deserve my compassion or
respect neither do i deserve the same
either way stop complaining
um
then patrick in chicago another way to
think about the pay gap is that while
women think that more money is what they
value they choose jobs that pay less but
reward them in other interpersonal ways
yes vic
pearl is the only woman worth simping
for thank you
um lady um pet shop lady on the couch
i'm sure you're great but you can't opt
out of certain topics just because you
don't want to speak about them on a
podcast
uh sentience
male male guests on the couch haven't
experienced
the male guest on the couch has not only
sugar-coated words for women but avoided
stats and facts you can make the claim
that people stand by their keyboard
while you lack stats and are
inconsistent as women while supplicating
for you and this is
simp-tastic levels um next time put some
money when you're saying something put
some money in it if you're going to oh
he did oh he did it yeah he did that
okay you can say what you like
god i'm not going to call your [ __ ]
because i can't think of words okay
there's original um the wnba can't dunk
they offered to lower the basketball
hoop to make it more exciting and the
woman took offense okay thank you guys
for all the super chats i appreciate it
so much appreciate you
um you guys are seriously a big part of
like what keeps the show going like we
could not
um
you know hire the people we're hiring
and do the things we're doing without
the super chats that you guys send so i
really really appreciate it right now
we're saving for a sound board so that
is like the new equipment upgrade so
thank you so much
okay so
we're talking about
the
the pay gap before
do you guys so does that change your
opinion a little bit on it now that kind
of stuff yeah yeah because it's kind of
like pushed in society that there's this
big pay gap but it's interesting because
it's really not as big as like they say
it accounts for maybe
three percent if that
okay that's interesting maybe i was just
too uneducated to speak on it yeah no i
mean something that's how we learn yeah
because
yeah it has changed my perception
obviously in terms of when you break it
down in like a a sports side of things
but from personal experience with
friends and family and they're like when
you're going toe to toe with someone in
the exact same position
there is there's definitely a pay gap
which i can
say exists and i wonder why
i could tell you why oh please please
enlighten me it's 60. 60 of women have
never asked for a raise
ever that's why i would say and they'll
quit their job before they ask for one
where men are when so there's a trait
called agreeableness and women are more
agreeable than men men are more
disagreeable that's why more men are
criminals because if you go to the
extreme ends of the spectrum like if
someone that's super disagreeable goes
to jail but someone that's more
disagreeable also makes more money
because they won't put up with it if
they don't feel like their boss is
paying them enough they'll say pay me
more i'm leaving women don't do that
and it's kind of like and i always use
this example in basketball like the
girls that are captains on the team are
always a little bit [ __ ] right a lot
of the time i don't know about you
this isn't personal i don't really i
don't know who i don't have that type of
relationship with them i mean like like
they're more willing to take charge and
they're more willing to like tell you
when you're wrong and okay so that's
that's it
and i'm naked are you on the basketball
team yeah we we played again
what to do
they don't get respected by their
teammates what they're voice captains
um i'm not dissing anyone but it's like
they need a bit more leadership but the
girls they've got that leadership
quality yeah but what i'm saying is like
women that display those qualities like
tend to get paid like it's more equal
close it's closer to what men make but
like women just don't ask for raises we
don't like conflict as much and our
biology has it rooted like in us that
way because
like we had to get along with a guy to
survive historically but you're saying
so it was 60 percent you said that don't
lose
some some women make more than men oh
yeah somebody yeah the ones who are
asking for it they're still not getting
it because they're a woman yeah i don't
know that's not true absolutely
we're talking 60 40. it's not 90 10.
well what yeah but the 16.
but 40 percent did
right a lot of friends and family have
asked for it and they're like like well
until so out of the 40 that did ask me
how many actually got it
out of the forty percent well like
probably not much
that's not true that's not true like
there's nothing
there no no there are companies that
have done internal studies trying to see
if like google they did an internal
study trying to see if there was a pay
gap between the men and the women and
they found out when they take into
account things like hours worked
like women women would make more than
men
so like they would pay women more and
those and those
in that study when they take into
account hours worked because if a man
and a woman are in the same job and a
woman works eight hours a day and the
man works 10.
after a year that's that's two hours a
day extra he's working
right so 10 hours a week 40 extra hours
a month by the end of the year the girls
are never gonna catch up yeah ever
and like women don't work as long of
hours so of course they're not going to
get the same raise as men do even if
they're my own job they wouldn't give me
the same amount of hours as a guy
because i was a girl so i'd get less
hours because i was a girl and they told
you it was for a girl yeah why didn't
you sue yeah i was thinking
guys got money what was that what was
the job um kitchen porter so it was like
my first job and they were like what the
kitchen part
what is that
like the guy the girl that busted the
dishes in the kitchen
yeah did you do as good of a job i was
probably the hardest worker there i'm
not even gonna lie mm-hmm
they said because you're a girl you
can't yeah they're like you can't get
some hours because it's like dangerous
for you to walk out late at night and
stuff like that and i was just like
i want the money stop worrying about my
health
i didn't ask about that you're not my
dad i want money well i i think that in
in general in most fields young women
are at an advantage because it's usually
men that are your bosses right they're
powerful and they're attracted to young
women and i think men are more likely to
like help girls they're attracted to to
be honest 100
like they're more willing like if a guy
asks them i think it'll be one reaction
if a girl asks them they're like oh i'll
take it like us i don't i don't know if
it's conscious i'm not saying they're
trying to do anything but i think men
have like a natural inclination to like
help women i agree yeah especially ones
that are they're attracted to i think it
just helps yeah it does so if you're
like a 22 year old woman like i think
you have a leg up over like a 22 year
old dude
yeah probably
there you go let's
let that could be due to that we don't
know the reasons behind it though
who cares about the reason reasons don't
matter but at the same time i agree i
think it comes from it comes from that
roles and in our essence men do feel
more protected towards women and feel
more like
they have more of an inclination to
respond and to help out with women it's
just in us it's just how it happened why
didn't i just get more hours like i
asked because he was worried about
because you said he was trying to
protect you same protector role like
they don't want you to get hurt
because you're the weakest like in that
case sure then like in that that was a
disadvantage to you but what i'm saying
is i think in general women have more
advantages in the workplace than
disadvantages i mean at the end of the
day there's an advantage for the guy
because he got more hours in that case
sure but i'm saying in general
i think women have an advantage more
than a disadvantage because also women
there are quotas so companies look like
engineering companies they'll take a
less qualified woman just so they can
get a woman yeah we have that in our
company actually we have um
this survey that we do to ensure that
obviously
we're seeing who's men and who's women
and actually there's more women in our
business than there is men
we get paid less though
as a standard
um
okay so you
yeah i've gotta make a move now okay
okay
it's been great
so
much so to close out the show um why
don't you tell he has a really great
youtube channel and a great we gotta end
the show early he's gotta get going yeah
i've gotta go somewhere i gotta go
somewhere i've gotta be somewhere yeah
i've got my i've got my own finger
winners talking podcast it's on youtube
every sunday uk time 8 p.m but yeah
we've been doing that for a while tuning
tuning in getting involved the link to
that's in the description guys it's
really great like he has some really
interesting discussions on there so you
should go subscribe
um and then why don't you tell the
people where they can find you
any final thoughts you guys want to say
go ahead do it now no but i like a lot
with the statistics at least yeah about
the pay gap and stuff like that yeah i'm
going to watch it back for the
statistics i'm going to take i'm going
to take them down and i'm going to
re-quote them on a sentence yeah they
are all good
do you no no you don't have something
but i still i do still stand by there
will be the odd anomaly of just you know
you know what i'm saying where you know
things just come to pass the way they
can do because i don't want people to
just give up because of the stats yeah
but the stats are accurate
and to you guys
a lot of girls will hear the stats and
they don't care like they just believe
what you they believe so i i really give
you guys credit and props for like
saying that you change an opinion on
something when you get new information
nice to have that yeah i wouldn't often
have it so i appreciate you giving them
to me yeah
thank you guys so much for coming um
we're gonna close out the show um all
right guys
as you guys know subscribe to the
channel for i'm so tired of some of you
watching this channel and you don't
subscribe it's free just hit the button
like right now right there okay also
guys we're enter we're doing membership
soon the lives are just gonna be members
only um for the chat uh it's going away
i'm giving you guys the warning now so
if you want to have chat privileges it's
five bucks a month it's literally only
five dollars you get chat privileges
and don't forget to